[موسيقى]
اجرى المنتخب الجزائري اخر حصه تدريبيه له
قبل المواجهه العربيه الخالصه التي ستجمعه
الليله بنظيره الموريتاني والتي يكفيه
خلالها التعادل لضمان التاهل الى الدور
الثمن النهائي محاربوا الصحراء وبعد
تعادلهم في الجولتين الاولى والثانيه امام
كل من انجولا وبوركينا فاسو يتمركزون في
الموقع الثالث بنقطتين وقد صبت سلسله
المفاجات التي حدثت بالامس في باقي
المجموعات في مصلحه المدرب جمال بلمادي
والذين اصبحوا في حاجه للتعادل فقط لضمان
التاهل بعد ان كان الفوز خيارا لا بديل
عنه ومن خلال الحصه التدريبيه الاخيره
يبدو ان الناخب الوطني سيجري العديد من
التعديلات على تشكيلته منها اشراك حسام
عوار والاعتماد مره اخرى على رياض محرز
برغم الانتقادات التي وجهت له في
المباراتين
السابقتين
نعم بالطبع اوافق على ان المباراتين
الاخيرتين لم يظهر خلالهما رياض محرز
بالشكل اللازم لكن لا تقتلوه مبكرا قبل
اشهر كان بطلا لاوروبا فيما يتعلق بخطت من
الواضح انك لا تعرفني لانني لن اقدم اي
معلومات ابدا الشيء الاكثر اهميه لنا هو
ان الفريق سيتمكن من التاهل للدور
الثاني وبدوره اجرى منتخب موريتانيا مرانه
الاخير قبل مواجهه الجزائر في الجوله
الاخيره من مباريات المجموعه لبطوله كاس
امم افريقيا وتسعى موريتانيا الى تحقيق
فوزها الاول في هذه النسخه من كاس الامم
الافريقيه بعد خسارتين امام بوركينا فاس
وانجولا وبعد ما كان المرابطون خارج
البطوله تقريبا وبعد نتائج باقي المجموعات
بالامس ايضا عاد الامل لاشبال المدرب امير
عبده من اجل التاهل الذي لن يتحقق الا
بالفوز على الجزائر في الديربي المغاربي
الليله ك ج ديزي
ستكون الامور معقده للغايه بالنسبه لنا
نعلم اننا سنلعب ضد فريق جيد جدا فريق
يتمتع بالجوده ولاعبين على مستوى عالي
سنبذل قصار جهدنا لاستغلال فرصنا هذا امر
منطقي وطبيعي سنحاول ان نكون على مستوى
عال من اجل
[موسيقى]
التاهل